[ __ ] yeah
are you okay Jenna do you need medical
attention
fudges joins mad at me because before we
started podcasting he wouldn't stop
saying podcast
pop up yeah it was funny for a minute
and then she know I was getting so angry
I was like Julian stop [ __ ] doing
that and then she decided that she
wanted to make me as angry as I am
that's where we are now but which leads
us speaking of which welcome to the
general Julian podcast ha ha [ __ ] [ __ ]
up that that'll be last one yeah okay
whatever you say that really [ __ ] eating
grin she's deep [ __ ] cuz that's a [ __ ]
eating grin eyed peas that you like you
for breakfast
you piece of [ __ ] for breakfast it's
disgusting what no what
yes yeah huh
so today on the podcast we thought it
would be a fun and entertaining and
worthwhile topic to discuss I guess um
what it's like you know as as you
Jenna's a youtuber and I am I guess now
one because I log as youtubers meeting
other youtubers in real life and the
expectations from other people you know
the people our viewers and what what
people think is like for us when we meet
other youtubers and also how we feel
like it goes you know because there's
certain there's a lot of different ways
it can go when you meet other youtubers
yeah for sure
and you more than anyone have expertise
on this because you've been there with
all sorts of people so I've met a lot of
people a lot of people a lot of
different types of people and a lot of
people in general in the public eye on
YouTube yeah I think the general
perception and I understand why it is
from people that watch YouTube videos
that may not be youtubers themselves is
that we're all like best friends
yeah and that we all like love each
other and then everything's like cool
and awesome I think it's like a really
from personal experience I feel like
I've met plenty of people that like
youtubers that will collaborate with
anyone look on a professional level if
you can even call it professional it is
it's it's our job you know
sort of in theory it's a choice but like
they can they can work with anybody they
can do anything anytime where like I'm
sort of on lonely island where like I
don't really want to collab with anyone
just because we both sort of do the same
thing for that being the main reason
right because well when you meet other
youtubers it's sort of like it used to
be like hey I'm you know this person and
I make youtube videos like the first
couple vidcon's and playlists was not
only to meet people that want to meet
youtubers but for us to meet each other
because you know three four years ago
most of us were not in Los Angeles there
wasn't like a super hub yeah so these
are yeah these events were really good
times for us to you know maybe cross
paths and meet each other and say hello
and it's a little bit weird when we meet
each other because we really most of us
a lot of us don't have that much in
common other than that we just do the
same thing yeah yeah yeah I think
viewers oftentimes expect us to be like
great friends and it's just sort of the
case that like it's like any two people
like you guys either hit it off or you
don't
yeah and I think that's easy to overlook
especially for the young people who kind
of view youtubers as entertainers right
like why don't you make a video with
this person or this person yeah and
sometimes like for me I don't know why I
have this standard or opinion in my life
it's like I don't really want to just
make a video with someone for the [ __ ]
of it like I would like to vibe with
them creatively beforehand or like you
know have a friendship or a solid sort
of like thing going on before we ever
work together because to me like working
with someone is kind of an intimate
thing like it's difficult for me to just
be thrown in a room and like do funny
stuff with someone that I don't feel
comfortable with do not any absolutely
absolutely why do you think that your
kind of stance or your feelings on
collabing slash meeting people in the
YouTube space is the minority why do you
why do you think not a lot of people are
like that I think it's because like it's
easier to just be like hey you're
so-and-so I'm so-and-so
let's [ __ ] make a video together a
because it's what people want to see
yeah and be because there's a lot of
people that want to make money on
YouTube they see it as a
cross-pollination of audiences and they
want to make money off of having another
person actually yeah yeah because
there's something very incestuous about
all the collab collab collab collab
collab we're like as much as I I want to
address that it's a thing and like you
know do some of it sometimes because
it's fun and people are really nice for
the most part yeah that can be good it
does get a little bit like [ __ ] where
you're like really this is all you're
ever gonna do is just sit in a room with
somebody else yeah and you know people
are always like let's make a video
sometime and sometimes I'm like yeah
let's why don't we like hang out for a
little offers yeah you know what in your
experience like knowing people and
getting to know youtubers before you
like vlog with them or collab with them
I guess is there in your mind in your
you know experience like when you think
about these times with people is there a
clear-cut like oh this person I hung out
with and therefore collabing with them
was like a completely different
experience than this person who I just
collab with like is it easy to remember
the times when you had known someone you
collabed with as a positive experience
like compared to the people you just
clogged with and didn't know well it's
always nicer to collab with someone
that's your friend because it's not work
it's nice like think about what we did I
dare you with Ryan Higa yes like we were
literally just hanging out yeah and
that's really I like it to feel like I
like to feel like this is something that
we would probably do in our free time
anyways and we're friends and it's just
like a nice relaxed thing it's yeah it's
not a there's no ulterior motive no for
sure for sure literally just hanging out
so it's difficult for me I guess
sometimes to see like the way that
YouTube culture is very much like at
this point it's like everybody needs to
work with everybody and it's a positive
thing it's a great thing people and it's
a great thing for the YouTube community
it unites us then a lot of friends yeah
for sure but like I just personally have
a little bit of a difficult time being
like yeah work with anybody
all the time forever yeah like I don't
think that people remember that some of
us are like 10 years older than some of
these people like it's al it's kind of
difficult sometimes yeah you know name
yeah I'm like 28 most of the people that
are popular in YouTube at the moment are
anywhere from 16 yeah 25 yeah for sure
it gets a little weird sometimes yes
and it's easy to forget that you know
that you because that you know you're
both youtubers and you both have big
audiences and you're both making similar
I guess you could say videos in a sense
I'm just giving a hypothetical what do
you think cuz you like you well while
we're doing this podcast we're about to
go meet up with Jesse and Jeana prank
vs. prank yeah they were some of my
first Youtube free you've known them
forever and you know briefly I did like
a couple of things with then yeah you
know it was more just like hey Jenna
pretend like you're in the bed with me
yeah yeah and I'm like I'm sure she's
not gonna like beat me up after it's
like no no no um but you know I've never
really worked with them they've just
always been my friends yeah and that's a
nice thing like I feel like when you
have this friendship with someone that
may happen with another person in the
YouTube space and you both really value
that friendship it never really comes up
in organically so to work with each
other if it does come up it comes up
because you both decided in some way
shape or form and conversation or
anything that wouldn't be fun right a
good thing a healthy thing to do right
but that's what I enjoy like you know
I've known Jeana and Jesse for what like
two years now you've known him for
forever and never have you know it's
always been and just let's hang out like
we're in town where you let's hang out
looks nice to see you and it's nice like
to have the idea and it's I guess it can
be like it's fun and it's fun you write
the friendship comes first and then
whatever you would do in your free time
comes second yeah whereas in a lot of
YouTube's relationships the the
collabing the video making comes first
and then ship comes second which makes
the friendship look good at it like
think of someone like Shane Dawson who
can collab with anyone all the time you
know he's lovely and amazing yeah you
know as vulgar
and whatever as he is he says he's a
really cool person very good but I think
it's hard for me to be like how can you
just like collab with anybody anytime
anywhere whereas I'm like I don't know
like I kind of want to like eat some
breakfast with them or like well I think
I think in a sense um you know person
like Shane he's so hot like a really
easy to get along with yeah he's a great
purple person and he's very very nice
he's like an incredible human being but
I think what what allows him to you know
collab with people who may not be a lot
like him is that he is able to
understand that he's not gonna be the
best of friends with people like he's
going into it knowing that yeah you know
may I could be friendly with them I
could mean I enjoy my time with him but
this isn't what I'm doing I'm not
looking for friendship alright working
with where is someone like I I have
everything sort of all confused
it's all very much like sex and love to
me where it's like I feel like if I'm
gonna work or someone I'm like hopping
in bed with them yeah so I'd rather like
trust them a little bit yeah for sure
you know it's it's difficult that's an
interesting but Shane has it completely
separated where it's like you know maybe
they're not best friends but they can
totally make videos together absolutely
but it's difficult for me and sometimes
it's weird when you meet other youtubers
and you know obviously everyone's life
is whatever they choose to show on
camera exactly so you might think that
you know someone or that you would get
along with them and then you meet them
and you're like I'm not feeling this
this is weird yeah you know yeah like
for whatever reason like I thought you
were gonna be really cool I'm not naming
any names so don't [ __ ] go there and
it's all subjective it's all on there
yeah no for sure but like you maybe you
just don't vibe with someone like the
way that you thought you would
absolutely you know absolutely there's
always that chance right well because I
find that people especially when they're
doing things that are you know not
vlogging like maybe they're they're
doing sketches or something like that
like you you think they're funny or you
appreciate what they do or what they
have to say yeah
but then just I was like a you know come
sit on my couch kind of thing we don't
get along ya know for sure
I think viewers think that everyone gets
on and that's that's the trouble as
nobody wants a badmouth each
I know no one's a bad person I know no
one's whatever it's just that you know
maybe you don't get along with everybody
yeah and you know what you keep those
situations in mind when you're with
someone who's another youtuber posting
an Instagram pic and all the comments
are clap clap clap clap and you keep
that in mind of the other experiences
when you're like oh this is what happens
when you know you do that and right now
I'm valuing what I have like I see this
person as someone I want to hang out
with
maybe I'll collab with him maybe I won't
that'll come up and organically or we
won't do it and for example you and Josh
have really hit it off absolutely I hung
out with Josh you know Josh d-town who
is Colleen Brandis Singh's fiance yeah
so we met at one of superwoman shoots
like two three months ago yeah and you
know we we were both extras and so we
just started chatting got each other's
numbers and then we went to a movie
together and then we just like
completely hit it off for like a really
really good forum as yeah and you know
there's only been sections of that that
we fought because he vlogs and I vlog
but I mean when I see him and when we
hang out we want to hang out like right
there did you know to hang out friends
to be friends because because it is one
of those things we were like wow I met a
good friend I'm excited to have met
someone who I really enjoy spending time
with who I really can trust and you know
will vlog a little bit here and there
and it's fun but we both I feel like
it's an unspoken thing when you meet
someone like that it's like you both
truly put the friendship before anything
else and I whatever else happens it can
happen naturally for sure like he'll
pull out his camera and will be like on
board right no I mean because we've had
that but it was also a mutual
understanding absence what you guys do
know absolutely in the four in the first
time I ever met him or the first time we
went on you know like a bro date or I
went to the movies he didn't pull out
his camera at all and I didn't pull out
pull out either in it he had said to me
you know he blogged about it after he
was like oh I just met Julian he's super
cool and we're gonna be friends and I
didn't let it but then he said I didn't
be friend yeah he said I didn't want to
put a camera in his face on the first
time we met nice of course I was gonna
be okay with he did but the fact that he
didn't because he didn't want to do that
is but it's like a big thing you don't
even that
very important step when you're trying
to be a friendly most people that are
vloggers are make daily vlogs or
anything like that are really really
conscious of not everyone wants to be on
camera yeah especially family friends
that sort of thing like just because
you're willing to put yourself out there
doesn't mean that everyone around you is
yeah and so I think that it's really
nice and is a sign of someone you know
that would be a good friend because
they're thoughtful is someone that you
know asks beforehand like I've been
dress it Jesse and Jeana when they came
over school also the other house they're
always like is it okay if we just like
vlog a little bit while we're here I'm
like just totally fine and you never
have to ask buddy thank you and they
asked every time it's ridiculous but
it's it's admirable is what it is it's
like it's like it's very respectful and
not a lot of people do that there's
people but know there might be people
that don't I'd say the majority of
people I know always ask well then
that's not a quick right yeah no for
sure for sure um but I just think like
it's a it's a delicate thing the line
between you know friendship and you know
working together creating something
together and I I don't really know how
well to do it I don't know yeah I don't
really know how to do it you know you
know it is that type of thing where it's
a fine line and on one side it's a you
know you have opportunities to meet
friends and know them and then the other
side you might have the opportunity to
work with them and maybe further both of
whatever you're doing and please each of
your father your fan bases or whatever
but it's a difficult thing to kind of
judge where one begins when one ends
well I've definitely worked with people
in the past that I wasn't great friends
with to begin with yeah and then it gets
real [ __ ] weird after that you know
what I mean it's sort of like you have I
don't really know how to describe it
unless you sit down and do it with
somebody yeah where it's like you have
this like intimate thing going on you're
making a video you're like being
vulnerable to the other person and then
you know you shut the camera off and
then you both say bye and go your
separate ways but you're like in
counseling
when you ask someone or you you know
this is a longshot analogy right now but
like you you open a session you talk
about someone's feelings and they open
up to you yeah you need to close this
session before they leave yeah you can't
leave someone exposed because if you
ever have a conversation with a friend
or something and you get you know really
deep into something they're just like
great yeah you know thanks for telling
me I got to go jump on a train like you
you leave there feeling very open and
vulnerable and exposed yes and that's
the only way that I can sort of connect
working with someone where it's like you
know you're open you're exposed you're
doing whatever and then it's like you
turn the camera off if you're not
friends and then you just go your
separate ways and it feels very it's
unnatural you feel open yeah um but if
you're if you're doing it with someone
that's a friend you know you turn the
camera off and then you like you hang
out and you just go back to go back to
whatever not having a camera on yeah
even though what you just did was
exactly what you were doing anyways yeah
you don't even think about the when we
worked with Ryan he got yeah it's like
all right we're just gonna shoot this
thing and we're all just giggling and
laughing and [ __ ] like Trent you're
doing a dare and then just turn the
camera off and then we're just back to
like the cameras on know who [ __ ]
exactly the camera could be on it would
be the same thing it would be the
exactly and I think that's that's like
that's the difference between working
with someone that you're already friends
with and someone that you're not to me I
think the analogy of like closing a
counselling session is is a good analogy
because you know you can imagine like if
you're not a youtuber that to people who
don't know each other she choose to
collaborate they get it done turn off
the camera and then it's like okay these
people don't [ __ ] even know each
other right they don't know anything
about each other they may be a big gap
in age like right what they just
expected to be oh you know I know even
in like in television or like a
Hollywood format or whatever the actors
spend time together they need a rapport
they need like an on-screen chemistry I
like you don't know each other that's
like you know when you have a billion
[ __ ] dollars to have that kind of
time and luxury you need to know each
one's area but like you know in the
YouTube world to me you always work
better together when you guys already
have a rapport
you already have a friendship that's
like you and then you see them again you
pick up right where you left off like a
good friend that you don't live near
well like you know I don't know and like
a late night format like someone like
Conan can sit and interview people
because it doesn't matter if they
[ __ ] know each other obviously it's
better when it's your buddy and you know
you have a great [ __ ] thing going on
but it's not like we sit and interview
each other we need to like you know
create something together there needs to
be chemistry right it's like when you
have a speaking of chemistry when you
have a [ __ ] like lab partner in
school if you [ __ ] like don't even
know the person and you're like fumbling
over the Bunsen burner and [ __ ] so many
lights each other's hands on fire like
it's all bad yeah but if you're with
your best friend and your [ __ ] you
know making some bonds absolutely
hydrogen was those kind of bonds
covalent ones it's always so much better
so I mean sometimes I feel left out of
the collab train but it's like it's just
something personal - personal choice for
me to you know not work with people
until I feel like it's it's natural it's
comfortable it's fun and like that's
that's just sort of how I feel yeah I
mean I couldn't be I couldn't I know a
lot of YouTube a lot I could say all of
it I mean I could safely say all of
YouTube has been really shown to me
about you I didn't really know much of
it at all before I met you and I am a
very extreme like like conservative and
then sometimes like way liberal like a
pig I'm on both ends of the spectrum in
terms of unpopular opinion like
everybody lies in here and then there's
a few of us that are just like [ __ ] them
in and like I work alone and I'm like
I'm terrified of life like all of that
do you mean they're like whenever
someone talks to me about YouTube my
opinions are always like not the
majority at all like I'm not with a
network I know that we're like never
really it's funny
yeah yeah and everyone's always like you
know not not on my train at all I just
draw it to true my train like into
wherever the [ __ ] I don't know for what
you think and then [ __ ] the rest I mean
it's like really like but it's easy to
feel like to compare yourself to other
people like when you see people doing
all this work we're talking about this
the other day yeah like [ __ ] Colleen
is on tour and like vlogs every single
day if you've got a [ __ ] Miranda
sings like all this [ __ ] going on it's
easy sometimes to sit back and be like
well what more can I do like I need to
be doing more like everybody is doing
all this stuff like I'm over here not
like is there something wrong with me
yeah and it's easy to fall into that
trap but I think that as long as you're
doing what you want yeah at the pace
that you want at a pace that's
sustainable that doesn't make you crazy
there's no need to ever compare yourself
to something yeah and that goes for a
lot of things not just like this not
just yeah yeah yeah and I think it's
healthy to remember that comparing
yourself doesn't really never work
doesn't never benefits 81 it's a very
easy thing to do well even natural it's
a human reaction because we're always
taught like where you rank and where you
are in the world absolute thing to do
like you know anything in terms of
comparing yourself yes but I don't know
man it's not a good sound a good way to
live your life no you just got a do you
you know what I mean you gotta float
like a butterfly do you floating a
butterfly man there's what it is yeah
but um it is easy for me sometimes to be
like you know the trend on YouTube is
everybody collab with everybody all the
time and you know what is what is it
about me or my ideas or my thoughts
that's sort of keeping me from going in
that direction and it's just sort of
that I I think I just want to be friends
with people before I work with them
before I jump into bed with them if that
makes sense
yeah and I think I think a few years
down the road you're gonna have friends
and that's a nice okay you're telling me
I don't have friends thanks Julian you
know
no I understand I just mean that you're
gonna happen these friends that you've
met throughout meeting them in the space
of YouTube and maybe not working
together and it's a nice thing to know
that you know maybe you're not friends
with them five ten years down the road
but the point is is that you're
developing real relationships with them
so that your time with them now and then
possibly in the future is an enjoyable
one
well the people that I've you know
chosen to be friends with and have
chosen to be my friend tend to stick
around for years yeah like I've been
friends with [ __ ] Ryan forever and
Jeana and Jesse forever and [ __ ] just
the people that you're a fan of real
people yeah like that real people are
good I like real people
I also gravitate towards people that are
like on a similar page of life as me
yeah generally yeah like it's hard for
me to relate to some of the younger
people that are creating because I don't
you know I don't want to party all day I
don't I don't really want to like do
this bro thing I'm I'm an adult yeah you
know absolutely absolutely it's [ __ ]
weird yeah it's all [ __ ] weird and
nobody knows what the [ __ ] they're doing
yeah that's the weirdest part always is
that we're always like a bunch of
chickens with their heads cut off yeah
but some of them pretend like they know
what those are the people who are the
furthest from understanding what's
really happen anything tells you they
were having his life that's that's the
weirdest part about the Internet is that
there's not like this look if you want
to be a singer you know there's a
relatively concrete path for you to walk
on of how to get there and you know you
put out some [ __ ] knee piece you put
out an album you [ __ ] yeah you go on
American Idol signed a contract with
somebody you know that's been done
before but I mean there's people that
have been breaking that mold but still
there's there's at least a path yeah
that you can walk on yeah that you know
will get you to where you want to go so
with the internet we're all just like we
don't know where it's going the path is
being right or I'm walking yeah I just
got a feather I'm in playing Altos
adventure and I'm hovering and I'm just
doing like six baskets
I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm doing
yeah no you're right it's crazy because
it really is happening right now and ten
years later from now people are going to
say oh that is the path right they did
that right that's where it ended them up
right like it's happening right now so
it's a crazy thing to think that we
don't really know what's going to happen
yeah and well I mean something that's
important to me is to not only recognize
and respect but like pay homage to the
people that have you been paved a path
as far as I got yeah before me Charles
Trippy [ __ ] Fred Leighton right here
Oh Ryan Hegel's before me everybody
ain't like years before me and
raywilliamjohnson like it's important to
realize that like some of the younger
people that I've met not like you guys
need to whatever perception you have of
like who I'm talking about please let
that go because this is like it's no
most people are so genuine and lovely
and grateful and spectacular oh yeah
there's been a couple of people where
she sort of bothered me where I'm like
you know that you're not the biggest
deal in the world and that people have
you know you know made it as far as they
had that you had an opportunity so that
people would take you see ya the
opposite of paying homage to homage to
their elders in this situation right
like they'll get an opportunity and
think that you know because it's easy on
the Internet to somehow think that
you're great or better than anybody else
when you're sort of just you know doing
you and people are being grateful for
that much yeah it's not that you are the
best or funniest or most talented like
we've just we've invested in you we find
something aren't you that I identify
with or that I like you or something
about you yeah but there are some of
these younger people that are handling
their success in a way that sort of
irritates me and that you know there's
been people that have done this before
you that have worked so hard to make it
even close to possible what you're doing
right and and to to make it so that the
general perception of the Internet is
not just that we make [ __ ] cat videos
and [ __ ] [ __ ] all day yeah there
is kernels of thought like yes most of
us do it from our houses because we
don't we can't really afford to [ __ ]
make house of
cards over here like whatever no you're
right you're right the people who are
not you have built respect for you and
what you do like what they have done has
made it so you know people has have
looked at the internet and instead of
saying oh this is a joke they say oh
well maybe it's not a joke right we'll
think of someone like Shane like Shane
used to just do your typical vlogging
and he makes short you made a movie made
a whole movie like Michael Gallagher
like these people just do the most
incredible work and they've made it so
that people see that you know you might
start somewhere when he starts somewhere
might start in your bedroom yeah but
they've really built up great ideas and
great work and they've taken what
they've created and turned it into
something even better
yeah and it's in ear right and it's a
it's a really important thing to
remember that right I just think that
the internet is like it's still [ __ ]
because there's so much going on but
that I don't know but let's just my idea
and that's just how I feel about you
know sometimes people are like why don't
you work with this person or do this or
do that and it's just sort of a personal
preference for me and it's also just a
little bit ridiculous to think that
everyone could always you know get along
like peas and carrots yeah anyone that
doesn't like dogs just can't come to my
house so there's that I mean imagine it
like okay so I don't know anyone that
doesn't like that no like imagine this
like a say you do IT right and someone
says hope you do IT Oh my friend John
does IT you guys should like do it
together right yeah yeah we like don't
like John you're nothing like John
you're ten years older than John like
why would you yeah yeah yeah so we're
like when you try and set people up on a
blind date huh you're like oh this
person's a brunette my friends also
Aboriginal you guys should do you guys
should basically just a they love each
other they'll hit it off I'm not weird
no but I mean for the most part the
respect level is there people are very
kind and nice to each other
almost everyone that I've met has been
nice to me I think I've ever met a
person that was a dick to me no I mean
yeah yeah no I've never had someone that
was like [ __ ] you Jenna
except for that girl in Texas no I'm
talking about other you toenails I know
you're right no you're right oh
absolutely absolutely there's never been
blatant disrespect know whether or not
you enjoyed or made friends with them
there was never blatant disrespect which
is a good thing to Rhett directly yeah
for sure and also I mean it's it's
different like there's a difference
between you know maybe not having a
great personal close friendship with
someone and just being like nice
acquaintance cordial yeah like it's not
even cordial like you totally are nice
and get along together when you're
around but there's just no need to have
like some crazy but there's a mutual
understanding of that you know which is
why it's nice right yeah I don't know
it's just a [ __ ] weird thing because
most of us most of us that are in front
of a camera in our houses where
ourselves yeah you know so though you
feel like the rest of the internet does
where it's like oh I know that person
you know that's my friend Jenna yeah I
totally get along with her if we met
yeah and then sometimes it's just
[ __ ] weird all around yeah cuz I'm
way weirder than people expect I think I
might be most of the problem like I'm
just so I'm weird I'm too weird I'm way
weirder than people think but the
weirdest you're pretty weird I like it
well thanks Jillian I like your weird I
think it's a it's a weird dynamic you're
you know if you put yourselves in the
shoes of mostly young people who watched
videos on YouTube especially like your
videos or my videos and stuff like that
and you learn so much about them through
all of what they put out on the Internet
and you form this world where you have
an idea of like who they are because of
everything that you've seen but really
that world only exists on the Internet
it only exists because the person has
chosen to put that world together for
you and so for you putting you know say
Jenna's world is here and say I don't
know youtuber bees here world is here
and I know both of them and they both do
this they both do that so why don't they
collab what but really it's like there's
a whole other life that they have no
idea about and it's very hard to
understand that especially as a young
person watching YouTube for sure and
some people are not as they appear
no not you see you there but in every
profession but yeah especially like you
like what you find out that like Mel
Gibson is a [ __ ] racist and a
[ __ ] my girl everyone's like wait
what like Michael Jordan for sure
exactly look when you figure out how
someone really is you're like oh that's
terrible but of course it happens on you
and it happens all the time
like it's because a person does
something yeah and then because some way
on the internet you never see people at
their worst which is really the biggest
judge of their character to really mean
very very true so you only see them at
their best you only see them even at
their worst they're gonna be at their
best worst you know what I mean like
you're having a bad day you got a blog
it's gonna be your best face that you
put on that day you're not gonna see the
[ __ ] public freakout that happened
ten minutes ago at Starbucks in your
public freakout go to reddit.com slash
our public freakout my favorite
subreddits oh yeah I mean that's we
don't have to talk about this thing no
no it's why I just I think it is kind of
a weird thing so talking about it
however much we can talk about it is
important because yeah gives people an
idea of where we're heads right I just
wanted to share my thoughts about that
and that I'm the unpopular opinion we're
just a couple oh well we're a couple of
puffins on your opinion puffin but
that's why we had this podcast because
sometimes we want to hear our thoughts
on something and that's it's a great
Avenue to be able to do that would you
know who I wasn't I wasn't too close of
friends with that I worked with recently
it was lovely and adorable Ricky Dillon
oh yeah he was fun I enjoyed hanging out
with him he's a cool guy and Tyler
Oakley when I work with Tyler he's such
like a charismatic funny happy person oh
yeah he's a funny guy when you're in the
same room with him you can't do anything
but just be so happy you know he is he's
magnetic he's exactly everything he's
it's like it's almost like he has
planned out what he said because it's so
electrical oh my god what she's so
magnetic it's not like him and I are you
know the best no you guys get along
great whenever you see each other he's
in [ __ ] Garrett's but like I had a
whirring with both of them yes yeah he
was funny and playlist for that like he
was in like the vlog for a second that
was funny you're just trying to figure
out we're just yeah we were like taking
a selfie together and I was like all the
lights good over here I was like oh shut
up
I mean that [ __ ] just totally off
topic like Tyler Oakley is just he was
just made to do anything and everything
in front of a camera because he really
is that magnetic in person yes I'm sure
a lot of you you know anyways good good
podcast that's good pocket I stated it
no I think I think this is one of our
things that we really just kind of had
to put on the table and you know hash it
out and talk not now like we disagree
but just like talk about it so people
could see us talking about it and - and
tell us your thoughts - if you have a
job like as a [ __ ] camp counselor and
all the kids are like why don't you guys
boyfriend and girlfriend
it's like I don't know cuz he's [ __ ]
weird out yeah relate related to heroin
I don't know kid wow you have lots of
heroin no but that's not my joke it's
not your job that's it well you gotta
stop using it well thank you guys for
listening and watching the podcast and
McCleod you did do it in on your video
what guys do when they're drunk it was a
nod oh I should have put like a little
stuffy item on there that was like
thanks epiclloyd yeah um well yeah
thanks guys we'll be back next week for
another podcast and obviously like we
said let us know your thoughts in the
comments and stuff like that and um yeah
well we'll do our best to be friends
with people in collab with them well I'm
not against ever have anybody on the
podcast
oh yeah we don't have any an interview
thing so I don't we don't have to be
friends with that absolutely that's why
the podcast it's is really fun Scott
know for sure yeah there's a difference
between like sitting and kicking it with
someone if we just have microphones not
having to create with them right yeah
when you have to actually create one for
a few so owner as meta as in my team if
you guys do have people that you want to
see how the podcast let us not mm-hmm -
anyways - completely contradicted
everybody go back to that but you're
right the punters don't like to have a
lot the podcast is a great format it
itself to me to be very raw meeting
people or you don't need to know them at
all that's you know what talk shows work
sort of you don't have to expose
everything to that and plus I love
interviewing I've done it for years and
it's we have you're really good at it
it's really [ __ ] it's I never thought
that it was like a particularly you know
hard skill until I heard Julian
interview fighters over the phone like
when we first started hanging out I was
a complete [ __ ] [ __ ] you really get
it thanks babe
yeah it was Shayna Baszler the first one
you heard huh well yeah she's dope she
my TV boy old friend yeah I said that to
her face I think she was like okay
alright there's a weird thing okay he
said it to Marina to her friend she
loved it she's all done we have no cute
go yells yells speaking of oils my
little coil is being pretty loud right
now so wouldn't have to get out of here
thanks for watching again guys thanks
parents let's see next week right on cue